30 miles north of Turin Italy buried
deep under the foothills of the Alps
enlightenment awaits under an unassuming
suburban house in northern Italy is a
giant series of underground chambers dug
by a group of non architects working
around the clock over 15 years the
project was done in total secrecy it has
become known as the eighth wonder of the
world I'm talking about the temple of
Domino it was a warm August night when
Alberto a rowdy and his believers sat in
his backyard at the foothills of the
Alps they watched a falling star shoot
through the sky decided now was an
auspicious time to begin their project
so with simple tools and hammers they
began to dig into the rock it's a
massive and intricately decorated
underground complex spreading over three
hundred thousand cubic meters connected
by hundreds of metres of tunnels and on
five different levels the structure
contains a large number of rooms some
with ceilings of over 25 feet tall one
room is a four-sided pyramid covered in
mirrors and topped with a glass dome the
ceiling of a room called the Hall of
spheres is covered entirely in gold leaf
and the walls and floors are done in
intricate murals and mosaics all done by
O Berta's followers and the project
stayed secret for over 15 years but the
jig was up the Italian police were on to
them show us these temples or we will
dynamite the entire hillside this is
what the Italian police said to Alberto
in 1992 and so a bear doe dutifully
complied and open the doors to let them
in the entire massive complex has a
distinctly 1970s new-age kind of feel to
it and it's said to correspond with a
journey
into oneself according to Alberto this
all started when he was a child and he
had visions which contained a great
temple filled with people living in
harmonious and idyllic existence
together it was his goal to recreate
those dreams and that was what he's
attempting to do the temple of Domino
once the Italian government knew of its
existence they ordered it destroyed but
an alkali from the locals reversed the
decision and the government even went on
to say keep building make it bigger
Oberto has since passed away
but the work continues there are now
tens of thousands of followers all over
the world and the temple is their Mecca
cult or not one of the fundamental
philosophies of Domino that individuals
are capable of much more than they
realize and certainly the temple is a
testament to what a small group of true
believers can accomplish subscribe here
and watch more videos here so I'm gonna
link to the former members site it's
called Domino inside out it's a
fascinating look into the cult aspects
of the group and vais made an incredible
documentary about them it's long but if
you want a lot more of the tunnels and
murals it's really worth watching